welcome back to cbs this morning we
just showed you how many parents are
worried about the new school year
as we continue our special school
matters series we're joined by cbs news
senior medical correspondent dr tara
narula
and she's here to answer your questions
tara good morning
we heard uh we heard some of the
questions before we're going to go to
them now
the first comes from melanie who wants
to know what to do if her child has
chronic
seasonal allergies she asks are they
going to be sent home
all the time that's such a great
question and i know a lot of parents who
are wondering the same thing if my child
goes to school and sneezes or coughs
or says they don't feel well what
cascade is that going to trigger
and so this is really a great time to do
two things plan
and communicate so you want to
communicate and plan with your school
and your school nurse if they have one
and really tell them you know my child
has seasonal allergies this is typically
how they present this is how we treat
them
and then you want to talk to your
pediatrician or allergist and get them
on a good regimen a lot of
allergy planning and treatment involves
starting medications early
and then one last tip is that the kids
are going to be wearing masks those
masks can attract pollen
and hold it in so you want to make sure
you're washing those regularly and one
little plug for vaccination very
important during flu season
because that's something else that can
potentially be confused with coven
good advice there the next question
comes from lindsay who
asked how will the lack of in-person
social interaction
between our younger kids impact their
learning and development
i love this question because i love the
fact that she's talking about social
emotional learning
you know this is really critical now
almost more than ever
and when we talk about social emotional
learning we're talking about kids
learning things like
empathy how to make decisions how to
communicate
how to regulate their emotions and even
talk about their feelings
and really that's something that needs
to be built into the classroom and while
it's harder to do
with distance learning it's something
that can be done online teachers can
incorporate that into their curriculum
families can talk about those things at
home and really
ask their children how they're feeling
and teach them how to regulate their
emotions
and especially if they have siblings
it's something they can work on and i
think
the important thing here is that kids
are resilient and if anything this is
going to build resilience in our
children and really
ultimately what they need is a loving
safe secure environment so as long as
you're providing that
our kids are going to be just fine sarah
with so many students learning remotely
one
one viewer wants to know if there are
concerns about young children
spending so many consecutive hours in
front of a screen
well i have two little ones as well and
we talk a lot about screen time in our
house and
it's not really a black and white issue
right now we do need to be flexible and
in fact the american academy of
pediatrics
released a statement in march
acknowledging the fact that we are going
to see increase in screen time use
the two important things really being
the content and the context and so
using those screens to interact with
family and friends is important
obviously learning to using it to learn
is going to be critically important
and what the aap really suggests is that
you preserve offline activities so
things like
the fact that it doesn't interrupt with
sleep or reading or
even connecting with family exercise and
just down
time to reflect we all need a little of
that we also heard from sarah who is a
grandmother
who will be caring for her 8 and 12 year
old grandchildren after school
she asks how do i protect myself and my
husband
from possible spread of covet while
they're here
well this is a tough question and the
reality is we're learning more and more
each day about how much
children really do transmit even if
they're asymptomatic
and i think you know clearly there are
things you can do in the home like
cleaning disinfecting
having proper ventilation opening the
windows but then when the kids come home
there's little steps you can take like
having them take their shoes off at the
door making sure they wash their hands
leaving their backpacks and belongings
maybe by the front door
and even changing their clothes all of
these little things can go a long way
but it's definitely
you know a tricky situation when you
have people who are elderly caring for
young children and those
elderly may be at increased risk of
severe complications
one more quick one tariff we could pam
wants to know how long covid could
actually live on books and surfaces
well we still think that the primary
route of transmission is droplets or
even potentially airborne and not really
through contact
there have been some studies that have
shown that kovit can live on surfaces
for hours to days
so cleaning and disinfection is going to
be important and really the cdc is
recommending that schools not only do
that but really avoid having kids
share things like pencils or markers or
things that couldn't be cleaned
very easily to have their own cubby and
locker so
taking these little steps is going to be
important because we don't have all the
answers yet on exactly how long
it can live on services that's part of
what makes it so confusing tara thank
you so much
we would also like to hear from students
we want to hear your questions
about the school year whether your
classes are in person or online
email your questions to coronavirus at
cbsnews.com